im bundestag wird heute wieder über
corona diskutiert es geht um die
verlängerung der epidemischen lager von
nationaler tragweite
es geht auch um die abschaffung der
inzidenz und über allem schwebt die
frage wie lange sollen die
einschränkungen noch bleiben und dazu
haben wir heute zwei top experten
zugeschaltet der spd
gesundheitspolitiker und korea experte
karl lauterbach und andreas gassen chef
der kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
lassen sie mich mit ihnen anfangen herr
lauterbach sie haben in den vergangenen
tagen immer wieder mit dramatischen
worten vor dem steigenden instanzen
gewarnt sie sprechen von einer
kompletten durchseuchung der ungeimpften
und fordern auch verschärfte maßnahmen
zum beispiel die 2g regel aber eine
frage dazu warum sollte der staat
überhaupt das recht haben ungeimpfte vor
sich selbst zu schützen
also selbstverständlich kann der staat
ungeimpfte vor sich selbst schützen ich
starte keine nicht einfach zusehen wie
ungeimpfte zum beispiel in ermangelung
von guten kenntnissen wie gefährlich das
virus ist in also einer falschen
einschätzung also wie viele fälle wie
viele menschen sich jetzt infizieren
werden man kann diese menschen doch
nicht einfach ihrem schicksal überlassen
also diese einstellung wer sich
infiziert ist selber schuld wenn man
diese einstellung zu ende denkt dann
hätten wir nie irgendwelche
beschränkungen des öffentlichen lebens
beschließen können vergessen ist dass
das leben der ungeimpften weniger wert
das ist eine richtige frage herr gassen
was sagen sie dazu was halten sie vom
neuen einschränkung es gibt ja debatten
wie wirksam einschränkungen überhaupt
sind was sagen sie zweig regel weitere
einschränkungen für ungeimpfte braucht
ist das jetzt also zum einen muss man
natürlich sagen jetzt leben geimpft und
umgebung dieser logischerweise gleich
viel wert die grundrechte beide
allerdings auch das darf man nicht
völlig vergessen an der geschichte und
jetzt muss man natürlich die frage
stellen zum einen wie wirkungsvoll sind
die maßnahmen die immer propagiert
wurden wenn man anderthalb jahre
zurückschauen kann man sicherlich hinter
die 100 maßnahmen dickes fragezeichen
setzen zum anderen muss man ja sagen
wie will man wirksam infektion
verhindern das ist wirklich so dass
sagen endlich alle biologen
übereinstimmt dass wir erleben werden
dass die menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen perspektivisch irgendwann mit
corona infiziert werden wie schnell wie
intensiv das wird wird man sehen und man
muss natürlich auch klar sagen der
großteil der menschen die sich mit
qualifizieren erkrankt unverändert ja
nicht schwer insofern muss es nicht ist
es ja nicht so dass jeder gern corona
erkrankt auf der intensivstation land
insofern glaube ich muss die
fürsorgepflicht des staates da irgendwo
auch ihre grenzen haben und offenkundig
wird der staat der die auch gar nicht
wahrnehmen können das konnte in der
vergangenheit auch nicht das ist ja eine
kontrolle illusion der wir ja aufsitzen
grundsätzlich ist natürlich richtig klar
ist es besser wenn man geimpft oder
genesen ist und ist auch eine wesentlich
sicherer prognose und für infektion von
anderen und für sich selber als wenn ich
nur getestet bin wissen dass die
schnellste ist eine gewisse
unsicherheiten haben deshalb glaube ich
trotzdem es wäre hier angemessen zu
sagen das wird ohnehin in einem gewissen
umfang die sagen wir die normative kraft
des faktischen regeln es wird
restaurants geben die sagen ich nehme
nur noch geimpft und genesen ist einfach
sicherer ist wenn die dann auch noch
vielleicht mehr bestuhlung zugelassen
bekommen ist das in ordnung dass der
staat das jetzt wieder versucht zu
regeln es wird auch an manchen stellen
mittlerweile etwas hilflos muss ich
gestehen herr lauterbach was sagen sie
dazu das ziel des staates in der korona
politik war ja immer die verhinderung
des krankenhaus kollaps droht der uns
noch und wenn nicht kommt jetzt der
korona strategiewechsel und wir fangen
an einzelnen menschen vor einer
erkrankung zu schützen
nein es werden natürlich nicht einzelne
menschen vor erkrankungen geschützt
und es ist auch nicht richtig zu sagen
dass also das alleinige ziel unserer
maßnahmen bisher also die vermeidung des
kompletten kollaps unseres
gesundheitssystems gewesen ist und dann
der staat muss hat hier schauen dass er
verhindert dass viele jetzt in kurzer
zeit erkranken auch schwer erkranken und
auch zum beispiel auch die kinder
schützen ich kann man sagen na ja das
ist alles nicht so wichtig da wären
nicht mehr so viele sterben und also es
wird zwar longo witt geben aber das sind
dann nicht so viele vielleicht 10 15
prozent der erkrankten bei den kindern
vielleicht fünf prozent aber trotzdem
das ist aus meiner sicht und hier
spreche als politiker und als
epidemiologe das ist aus meiner sicht
nicht richtig wenn man das vermeiden
kann durch relativ geringe
einschränkungen das sind ja
einschränkungen die nur die ungeimpften
betreffen und bei den ungeimpften haben
wir jetzt hat eine sehr hohe incidents
die dürfte also sich sicherlich bald
also in 200 der bereich bewegung in also
städten wie leverkusen zum beispiel muss
man voneinander incidents bei den
ungeimpften von 600 ausgehen das kann
man ja nicht laufen lassen somit die
ungeimpften selbst zu schützen indem man
für ungeimpfte regeln erlässt die also
die freiheitsrechte da einschenken wo
die ungeimpften besonders gefährdet sind
aber nur in diesen bereichen das scheint
mir gut vertretbar zu sagen und das ist
auch die position der
bundesjustizministerin die in der
einschätzung der für mich maßgeblicher
ist also als die
interessanten also und bedenkenswerten
äußerungen von herrn gassen aber wir
gehen hat dort hinein wo wir hinein
müssen und beispielsweise so ein modell
wie in hamburg dass man also die
veranstalter oder beispielsweise
gastwirte oder die club-betreiber
auffordert zweig zu praktizieren
mit voller auslastung oder 3g wenn also
die auslastung die kapazität reduziert
ist das ist aus meiner sicht vollkommen
vertretbar und würde stark wirken weil
das schützt die ungeimpften zum einen
dann vor infektionen und zum zweiten
gibt es einen anreiz für ungeimpfte sich
impfen zu lassen wenn herr lauterbach
jetzt von der gefährdung von kindern
spricht halten sie diese rhetorik für
richtig oder glauben sie dass das
eventuell noch mehr schäden zur folge
haben wird wenn schulen wieder dicht
machen wenn kinder auch gar nicht mehr
ins restaurant gehen können wenn sie
nicht geimpft sind ja also zunächst mal
kann man sicherlich eine wahl zwischen 2
und 3 g mit kapazitätsanpassungen machen
das glaube ich ist konsens aber sie
sprechen es an neun millionen kinder
haben gar nicht die möglichkeit sich
impfen zu lassen weil es keinen
zugelassenen impfstoff gibt und insofern
ist ständig mal einfach wo die von mir
möchte am wochenende essen gehen dann
bleiben die kinder unter zwölf zuhause
oder vom restaurant stehen das sind ja
dinge die nicht praxisnah und praxis
realität geworden sind insofern glaube
ich muss man hier differenzierter
vorgehen und das thema longo wird das
ist ja wir hatten heute was sie waren ja
selber mitarbeiter letzte montag bei der
expertenanhörung im bmg anwendungen
gesessen es gibt bisher eine sehr
unklare daten angst da wird es irgendwas
geben das ist glaube ich unstrittig ob
und in welchem umfang ist noch völlig
unklar es gibt untersuchungen die kinder
sich angeschaut haben mit entsprechenden
katic ähnlichen symptomen
interessanterweise hat ein großer teil
von denen überhaupt kein corona gehabt
also was nachher anlagen kogit bleibt
muss man sehen
größeren von 10 15 prozent sind
sicherlich im moment durch keine
datenlage gedeckt und fünf prozent bei
den kindern werden aktuell in
deutschland
2008 100 gemeldete verdachtsfälle von
lugo wird bei unter 18 jährigen da sind
wir also im bereich von 0,0 prozent also
fünf prozent ist hier schon so ein
bisschen wieder die die angst corder das
stört mich so ein bisschen an der ganzen
sache natürlich muss man das
wissenschaftlich serie das aufarbeiten
forschen aufarbeiten und erst dann kann
man's epidemiologisch aufarbeiten es
gibt verschiedene dinge die wir noch
nicht völlig erkennen es gibt teams
syndrome es gibt auch für tig syndromen
die gibt es auch bei allen anderen bei
virusinfektionen immer wieder mal ob das
ein crooner spezifikum ist muss man
sehen also ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen weit voraus griffen die
wissenschaftler die sich damit intensiv
befassen haben zumindest bisher keine
klare aussage ob und was und in welchen
größer und somit eine gefahr für kinder
und auch erwachsene sein kann das heißt
nicht dass man das läuft ist wird das
geben wir sehen ja auch solche
krankheitsbilder wie sehen sie nun bei
weitem nicht in dieser häufigkeit und
von daher glaube ich
geht es auch ein gang gang niedriger
natürlich müssen wir das im auge
behalten aber ich glaube wir werden auch
erleben dass wieder die versprechen der
bundesregierung an der stelle nicht
eingehalten werden ich glaube dass die
schulen sind in teilen ja schon nicht im
vollbetrieb zumindest hier wird
unverändert glaube ich das nicht
durchgehalten und das sich zunehmend
bedrohlich weil wir massive zunahmen an
psychischen problemen bei kindern und
jugendlichen erleben und zwar in einem
umfang der wirklich besorgniserregend
ist herr lauterbach sie haben getwittert
an den schulen ist das schlimmste zu
befürchten sie waren vor fünf prozent
longo wird herr gassen sagt dafür gibt
es noch keine wissenschaftliche basis
sie twittern sehr viel über die gefahren
für kinder durch corona aber nicht über
die nebenwirkung von lock down
warum
weil wir keinen doktor machen werden
also die gefahren eines lektors bestehen
ja gar nicht wehren kann locker machen
aber schoss nämlich eine schar dinge
also klar stellen zu
lassen sie mich ein paar dinge
klarstellen zunächst einmal aus dem
fahrradkorb also die frage eben also
eingeleitet haben sprachen sie von also
meiner rhetorik zu longo wird bei
kindern ich habe keine rhetorik
vorgetragen also das ist keine rhetorik
das ist einfach schlicht nothafen ich
weise darauf hin dass es also bei
unklarer gesamt studienlage
gesamtbetrachtung der studien dieses
bisher gibt ein long beach bei kindern
gibt meine schätzung ist dass es fünf
prozent sind auf der grundlage der
studien die es gibt das entspricht auch
ungefähr der einschätzung des office of
national statistics in uk wo man die
also präzises der erhebung
repräsentative erhebung zu longo vita
kindern macht aber jetzt lassen sie es
uns nachher drei prozent sein oder
meinetwegen 6 prozent sein es ist auf
jeden fall ein großes problem zum
zweiten longo wird da kindern bedeutet
nicht corny kritik sind rom könig fertig
syndrom kommt bei kindern auch vor ist
aber gott sei dank sehr viel seltener da
ist die zahl deutlich niedriger also ein
sehr schwerer komplikationen und zum
dritten was vergessen sagt dass es auch
bei anderen viruserkrankung vorkommt das
stimmt aber die wahrheit ist auch die
dass die wissenschaft ganz klar zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt zeigt dass diese
besonders gefährliche komplikation bei
kubi viel viel häufiger ist als bei
anderen virus erkrankungen zb bei grippe
also und meinetwegen wenn man das
vergleichen wollte könig fertig syndrom
nach grippe kommt vielleicht bei einem
von 200 fällen vor bleibt fit ist das
eine ganz andere liga somit sind das
gefahren die wir ernst nehmen müssen wir
werden aber darauf nicht reagieren mit
schulschließungen oder einem lockdown
sondern wir können darauf reagieren
indem wir die
fallzahlen bei den ungeimpften
senken dann wenn die inzidenz dort sind
ist auch das risiko für kinder die sich
unter zwölf noch nicht impfen lassen
können viel niedriger das heißt die
strategie ist hier die über die senkung
der zahl der ungeimpften und über die
senkung der inzidenz bei den ungeimpften
das risiko für kinder abzusenken dann
ist auch weniger schulauswahl weniger
kinder müssen in quarantäne weniger
kinder gehen in das risiko hinein zu
erkranken das ist aus meiner sicht eine
vollkommen logische und auch
funktionierende strategie das hat auch
nichts mit staatsversagen oder ähnlichem
zu tun aus der gassen benutzt ihr ganz
großer worte quasi schon also
ich sag mal das ganz große besteck der
regierungskritik es geht auch einfach
schlicht und ergreifend darum sind wir
jetzt bereit bei den ungeimpften hin zu
gehen und sagen wir fordern die
restaurants und die hochrisiko bereich
der auf sich zu entscheiden entweder
drei gehen nur den einsatz noch noten
entweder drei geht leider die und
beschenkte kapazität oder zweig und
volle kapazität herr lauterbach vielen
dank für ihre ausführung das war eine
spannende corona debatte wir führen sie
an anderer stelle sicherlich fort
[Musik]